let's now go to your voicemail every
time that a story breaks over the
weekend and it's a story that at least
two somebody in our audience appears to
be a story that isn't a good story for
liberals or progressives or Democrats or
whatever the voicemails pour in saying
David I can tell you're deliberately not
covering this because it's bad for you
here is one such voicemail yes mr. david
pakman can you please answer on your
soul why you are not discussing anything
at the FBI related email incidents
window reclaiming how this is not huge
news yeah otherwise I think it's further
proof that you are a shell and you are
in bed with mr. Bill Clinton yeah okay
listen that's Troy York by the way doing
yet another one of his many voices which
are always it's always just some some
very angry caller once again the show is
monday through friday the friday show
was done when this was breaking and we
just weren't in on saturday and sunday
and every time this happens Pat this is
at the seven day a week so we do get a
weekend I'm sorry I'm sorry that we get
a weekend and staff gets to rest but it
we covered it it was the lead story
today yeah there's some people who have
the penny the opinion that any time a
story goes against Hillary Clinton in
her campaign that we just don't cover it
we cover it all the time we do at we we
cover it constantly and as I mentioned
at the beginning of this of the show the
investigation hasn't even been reopened
I don't know if anybody who thinks that
the investigation has been reopened into
Hillary Clinton clearly didn't read FBI
director James Comey letter because that
is not what he said on the bonus show
today reportedly Donald Trump offered
chris Christie the opportunity to be his
vice presidential running mate and then
took it back we will talk about that we
will talk about a story invar involving
service dogs that has made it to the
Supreme Court and we will also talk
about and and uses goin crazy about this
i read this might be on the front page
of The Drudge Report the david pakman
show 2017 Callen
is now available and you can get it at
david pakman.com slash calendar 17 check
it out get the calendar it's
extraordinary this i can tell you win or
lose Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump
this is going to be a calendar that will
be relevant and entertaining with the
comic strips that it includes through
the entire year of 2017 david pakman.com
slash calendar 17 and of course if you
just want to sign up for membership and
get access to the bonus show that can be
done at david pakman.com slash
membership